Democratic frontrunner Joe Biden and
Bernie Sanders are Criss crossing the
country ahead of the next slate of
presidential primaries six states will
hold their votes next week including the
battleground state of Michigan which
Sanders narrowly won four years ago
Biden leads the delegate count after a
presumptive win in Maine California is
leaning to Sanders but that race hasn't
been called yet and Ed O'Keefe is
following this and what are the
candidates up to to keep up the fight
well that's one big question mark for
them this morning Anthony senator Bernie
Sanders and former Vice President Joe
Biden are now preparing for a tough
fight over the future the Democratic
Party that's set to expose some of the
big differences they have over key
issues this idea that we didn't have a
movement look at the results look at
who's showing up former Vice President
Joe Biden is calling his campaign a
movement while senator Bernie Sanders
acknowledges that his movement has
struggled to bring out new voters think
that will change in the general election
but I am audibly honest with you we have
not done as well in bringing young
people across it is not easy ahead of
next week's critical primary in Michigan
a state president Trump won by just over
10,000 votes Sanders is highlighting his
differences with Biden Michigan was
decimated by a terrible terrible trade
deals NAFTA PNTR with China which cost
our country some four million
good-paying jobs I walked the picket
lines against NAFTA I went to Mexico to
see what NAFTA would do Jo voted for
those terribly beans Biden did vote for
NAFTA but the former vice president says
he believes future trade negotiations
should include input from labor and
environmental leaders after his
surprising turnaround on Super Tuesday
Biden's campaign is getting another
boost I'm glad to say I endorsed Joe
Biden former New York City Mayor Michael
Bloomberg who spent more than five
hundred million dollars on his own run
said he'll support Biden's candidacy
it's the Bloomberg comes on board Biden
of the candidates and he will solidify
his support with the political
leadership we're taking that on we're
running a grassroots campaign but the
Sanders campaign appears to be seeking
to broaden support
this new ad featuring former President
Obama is evidence that bernie is
somebody who has the virtue of saying
exactly what he believes as you saw that
new ad includes a clip of mr. obama and
sanders back in 2016 on the day the
former president decided to endorse
sanders as then opponent Hillary Clinton
in response to the ad Sanders said that
while the two were not best friends they
talk every now and then and that he
respects mr. Obama's decision to
withhold his endorsement until there's a
nominee but Tony I got a believe
whichever aid took that footage is is in
good shape with senator Sanders because
he's got something there to prove that
he's talked to the former president yeah
they may not be close but they have
taken pictures together exactly thank
you very much
you